[Music]
on this Monday night a new plane load of
Canadians returning from China another
flight on its way to CFB Trenton plus
China's mission to disinfect and protect
and the UK's new plan to stop the corona
virus from spreading their intensifying
anger and more arrests in the fight
against a pipeline the Democrats who
want a defeat Donald Trump get ready to
duke it out again our jackson prosecco
is in New Hampshire tonight plus the
push to change the Oscars same old
script parasite as a non English film
repeatedly pushes the envelope
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
another plane carrying Canadians out of
the heart of the new coronavirus
outbreak has taken off from China
Canada's foreign affairs minister says
the second chartered plane has left
Wuhan it is on route for CFB Trenton
with a refueling stop in Vancouver
passengers will join hundreds of other
evacuate already under quarantine
meanwhile the cases keep multiplying on
board the diamond Princess cruise ship
more than 2,500 passengers remain under
quarantine in the port of Yokohama Japan
the ship's owner says sixty-six more
people are now confirmed to have the
virus including one more Canadian that
nearly doubles the total number of cases
to 136 the vast majority of the cases
though are still in China officials
there say there were 108 deaths in the
past day that's the highest in a single
day and it brings the overall death toll
to over 1,000 that means this new
coronavirus has killed more people than
SARS
and the outbreak is still spreading
Chinese media is reporting there are now
more than 43,000 cases worldwide most of
them in China these pictures of mass
disinfection have emerged from who Bay
province that's where the outbreak began
and it's where most illnesses and deaths
are occurring this video was released by
state media it's not clear what is being
sprayed or what impact it might have
crews are reportedly targeting cities
across who Bay Province and will spray
disinfectant twice a day we'll have more
on the efforts to contain the outbreak
in China in just a moment but first to
the latest on those Canadians stranded
on cruise ships
Michael Couture has tonight's top story
an 8th Canadian who was on this cruise
ship has contracted the new coronavirus
Global Affairs Canada says the person is
now in a Yokohama hospital while 254
other Canadians on board that boat
remain in quarantine including Greg
Erik's who says he's lucky to have this
balcony view even though it's of the
port and he's just happy to ride out the
quarantine on the ship the Canadian
gonna send a plane and take
it's all home and still go through this
in Trenton well we'd be on Canadian soil
that'd be nice but I bet they don't feed
us as well and passengers would miss
displays like this a group of people on
jet skis put on a water show to break up
the day a welcome distraction with life
on board a challenge for people like
Canadian Roger Maniscalco and his wife
his medication is this evening and so we
we put in our order when the quarantine
first happened you haven't heard
anything I'm getting a hold of anybody
is very challenging hundreds of
Canadians are stranded on two ships in
Asia and the Foreign Affairs Minister is
watching the situation closely I spoke
yesterday again with this group CEO of
all in America to make sure that we were
offering all assistance to Canadians
onboard we're also speaking with the
Japanese authorities to make sure that
every Canadians receive all the medical
attention that they need meantime the
second Canadian Charter to repatriate
people stuck in Wuhan China is on its
way back to CFB Trenton in Ontario with
a hundred and eighty five people on
board
health officials say they will be
staying separate from the first batch of
evacuees we're trying to make sure that
their quarantine period would start when
they land would ask to have continued so
they don't have to reset the clock so
you're gonna make sure the two groups
are not coming late to that end there
are already designated times for
evacuees on the base to enjoy outdoor
air several times a day people are
illegally
late today Canada's chief Public Health
Officer reiterated calls for Canadians
to self isolate for 14 days if they're
returning from the Hubei Province of
China dr. Teresa Tam says about 70 to 80
travelers make that trip on a daily
basis and she feels it's a prudent step
as this outbreak evolves Donna okay
Michael Couture in Ottawa thanks the
United Kingdom is taking aggressive new
steps to try to stop the spread of the
virus within its borders there are now
just eight confirmed cases in the UK yet
public health officials today declared
the virus an imminent threat crystal
commencing explains what that means and
why officials say it's necessary the
virus has hit this Medical Center in
Brighton England where a staffer is the
second British health care worker to
contract the illness the British
government now has the power to
quarantine people believed to be at risk
of spreading the virus by force if
necessary it designated to isolation
facilities a hospital near Liverpool and
a conference centre northwest of London
officials say that while the virus poses
an imminent threat to public health the
risk of contracting it inside the UK is
moderate and they want to keep it that
way the detection of this small number
of cases could be the spark that becomes
a bigger fire but for now it's only a
spark
but that spark is enough for British
Airways to cancel all flights to Beijing
and Shanghai until April in an effort to
calm nerves in the Chinese capital
President Xi Jingping made a show
visiting clinics in a mask he also spent
time outside meeting with residents
let's not shake hands in this special
period he said you should always remain
confident we will be able to contain
this epidemic eventually the wh show for
its part has deployed a team of experts
in communicable diseases led by Canadian
doctor Bruce Aylward
when asked if Chinese officials are
sharing all of the information they have
the WH OHS director-general
pivoted away from politics that's how we
should see the threat as one humanity
against a virus which we don't know very
well dr. Bruce Alberts
team is now on the ground in Beijing and
more will be joining it's all in an
effort to gain insight into this virus
now the Canadian doctor is a bit of a
rock star in the world of epidemiology
most notably he led the wh o--'s
response at the height of the Ebola
outbreak in West Africa Donna all right
crystal commencing in London thanks
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau paid a
surprise visit to Canadian forces in
Kuwait making a detour there while on
his trip to Africa and Europe it's been
a tense six weeks for Canadian troops
there after an escalation in tensions
between Iran and the u.s. our chief
political correspondent David akin is
traveling with the Prime Minister David
well Donna this really was kind of a
pitch stop for the prime minister he
spent about 90 minutes on the base most
of that shaking hands with the troops
Canadian Forces members who are serving
here as part of operation impact about
650 Canadian soldiers are involved in
operation impact mostly in training and
intelligence missions in Jordan Lebanon
and Iraq but many of the soldiers
stationed in Iraq were pulled back to
Kuwait they were trying to avoid getting
caught in the crossfire when Iran fired
missiles at US bases in Iraq in
retaliation for the killing of Iranian
general Qasem Soleimani on January the
3rd you've all had a volatile past few
weeks it made for nervous family members
back in Canada your families were
certainly worried about but all
Canadians are worried about was your
safety Trudeau in the midst of a week of
travel that is taking him across Africa
told the troops the country was grateful
you step up every day far from your
loved ones far from your families
because you believed in the values that
Canada stands for the military would not
permit any on the record interviews with
uniformed personnel Monday but the
Foreign Affairs Minister says those
troops who had to be pulled out of their
mission in Iraq are keen to be back at
it they want to be going back to their
normal duties but obviously this need to
be done in a safe environment
the invitation of the host nation now at
the end of this week of travel for the
prime minister he's going to be in
Munich Germany for a big defense and
security conference lots of foreign
ministers and defense experts and it's
really going to be there that we're
going to have the substantive
discussions about the future of peace in
Iraq about the threat in Iran and where
Canada fits in with all of that Danah
lots to discuss David akin in Kuwait
City thanks
as the RCMP in northern BC continue to
enforce a court order and remove
protesters opposed to a natural gas
pipeline their supporters are disrupting
travel and trade elsewhere in the
country for a fifth day many via rail
services between Ontario and Quebec were
blocked supporters of the would so and
hereditary chief setup on a key CN rail
line near Belleville Ontario leaving
many travelers stranded 21 services
between Montreal and Toronto and between
Ottawa and Toronto were cancelled
because of the blockade since Thursday
more than 100 Via Rail trains have been
cancelled and more than 16 thousand
passengers affected CN Rail has been
granted a court injunction to remove the
protesters via says its trains will not
operate until the issue is resolved and
early this morning dozens of supporters
of the would so it and hereditary Chiefs
were arrested in Vancouver
after a BC Court granted an injunction
to remove them they've been blocking
access to Canada's busiest port and to
Delta port in to Wasson it's all a show
of solidarity for what's happening on a
Forest Service Road in northern BC RCMP
are enforcing a BC Supreme Court
injunction to clear protest camps
they're so coastal gas link workers can
build a six billion dollar natural gas
pipeline
what so itand hereditary Chiefs maintain
no pipelines can be built through their
territory without their consent though
elected Chiefs have consented today
protesters say the RCMP made more
arrests and on the future of another
pipeline the trans mountain expansion
from Alberta to BC the federal
government is launching a new round of
consultations Finance Minister Bill
Morneau says up to 129 indigenous
communities will be engaged to ensure
they have what he calls a direct
economic stake in the project this next
step will be focused on different models
of economic participation such as equity
based or revenue sharing options and
will seek to build momentum towards a
widely acceptable option for the groups
that were consulting with several
indigenous led groups are interested in
buying the pipeline the talks will also
explore whether participating
communities are prepared to work
together through an existing entity or a
new one Morneau says the government will
profit when it sells the Trans Mountain
pipeline despite the 70% increase in
construction costs estimates announced
last week a major data breach in Israel
coming up how the personal information
of millions of voters was exposed
four members of the Chinese military
have been charged by the US with hacking
the credit monitoring agency Equifax it
happened in 2017 and it was one of the
largest data breaches in American
history
the personal data of nearly a hundred
and fifty million people including 19
thousand Canadians was compromised
including Social Security numbers and
addresses the American attorney general
says China has a voracious appetite for
Americans personal information our cases
reveal a pattern of state-sponsored
computer intrusions and thefts by China
targeting trade secrets and confidential
business information hackers were able
to exploit a security flaw to obtain
login information they're also suspected
of wiping logs in an effort to cover
their tracks
none of the four Chinese men charged are
in custody and officials admit there's
little chance they'll face trial in the
u.s. the RCMP says it's aware of the FBI
investigation and is prepared to help
upon request there's been a serious
security lapse involving an app that
promoted Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu and his Likud Party it exposed
the personal information of six and a
half million Israeli voters the app is
used for campaign management Prime
Minister Netanyahu's party reportedly
uploaded the entire national voter
registry to it but failed to secure
personal details it exposed voters names
identification numbers phone numbers and
addresses raising fears about identity
theft and foreign interference no
hacking skills were even required to see
it cyber security officials across the
world have warned new technology is best
kept out of the hands of election
officials and political parties Israelis
go to the polls in March the third time
in less than a year the little state of
New Hampshire is in the political
crosshairs in the US tonight
the first Democratic primary of 2020
takes place there tomorrow it's all
about choosing a candidate who can beat
President Trump in November and this is
shaping up to be an unpredictable race
our Jackson prosecco is in New Hampshire
tonight
Jackson Donna there's a clear sense that
things here are shifting and in many
cases voters seem less bound to one
specific candidate and more interested
in picking the person they think is
best position to win in Plymouth New
Hampshire they trudged through the snow
to hear from a political phenomenon heat
buddha james the 38 year old former
mayor won the iowa caucuses and is
surging in new hampshire polls this is a
moment for bringing as many people as we
can into the picture
curiosity is growing mayor Pete as they
call him pitches himself as a moderate
claiming to be less extreme than Bernie
Sanders yet more progressive than Joe
Biden the picture where your only
choices are between a revolution or the
status quo is a picture where most of us
don't see ourselves the strategy has
worked his rallies have a knack for
drawing in undecided voters what are you
curious to hear from people to judge I
guess I just want to really see the
passion of fire I don't want to vote for
like someone who has no chance if Budaj
edge does well in New Hampshire it could
very much hurt the chances for Joe Biden
experience whose campaign is now hoping
to recover from a disastrous performance
in Iowa while holding the line here
characters on the ballot the character
this country's on the ballot we have a
big thing tomorrow in recent days
senator Amy Klobuchar has seen her
numbers surge to surpassing Biden
but the biggest threat to all of them
maybe Bernie Sanders we will not forget
education we will not forget teaches a
crowd favorite here who is backed by an
army of loyal supporters who may not be
willing to back any other candidate
it is very critically important to me to
be here for my grandchildren for the
future of this earth for the future of
children everywhere one very likely
scenario is that Sanders wins and budda
judge finishes a strong second that
would put the squeeze on Joe Biden and
Biden's camp already senses this is a
real possibility they are now suggesting
they're more interested in winning
States further down the line like South
Carolina Donna all right lots at stake
Jackson Prosecco in New Hampshire Thanks
ahead from floods to powerful winds a
huge storm batters Europe
[Music]
watching global national pilots do train
for this but still it's not the kind of
landing anyone relishes flights wobbled
their way into Zurich Airport as a
storm-battered northern Europe with gale
force winds
storm Kira has triggered multiple severe
weather warnings and disrupted travel
across Europe including in Germany in
France in the UK air rail and ferry
services are affected and at least 200
flood warnings are in place across the
country and the storm has already caused
blizzards in Scotland and northwest
England some devastating developments in
Ontario a father and his four year old
daughter who disappeared while on a hike
on Sunday have been found dead police
believe the pair fell from a cliff their
bodies were found at the base of an
escarpment near Milton Ontario the young
girl has been identified by her mother
and stepfather and they tell global news
they suspect foul play is involved
because the girl has been at the center
of a long custody battle they were due
back around 5:30 p.m. and when they
weren't received back we got a call from
a worried party about 7:30 p.m. that
they had not returned the terrain they
were found in is known to be difficult
it was also raining and snowing at the
time police say the case is not
considered a homicide at this stage next
oscar makes history as parasite takes
Hollywood's top prize Cynthia did such a
great job in Harriet hiding black people
that the Academy got her to hide all the
black nominees
that's comedian Chris Rock he got some
laughs last night at the Oscars pointing
out only one african-american actor
Cynthia areevo was nominated this year
she played Harriet Tubman who escaped
slavery and helped hundreds of others do
the same
there was a lack of diversity this year
19 out of the 20 acting nominees were
white and all of the nominees for Best
Director were men I thought there was
something missing from the list this
year vaginas that said the Academy did
make history this year the South Korean
movie parasite dominated the night
winning four Oscars and his Eric
Sorensen explains it beats some of
Hollywood's most seasoned filmmakers
joon-ho it was long overdue at a
ceremony to honor the world's best
motion pictures a non-english language
film finally won the top prize
it took 92 years at a South Korean movie
called parasite a dark comedy in which a
lower class family infiltrates and
outwits an upper-class household you
could sense the joy and relief that
Hollywood got it right finally conceding
the best film could be made far away in
a different language in bed just how
about the Toronto moolah so queer yeah
when I was in school I studied Martin
Scorsese's films just to be nominated it
was a huge honor every year beyond the
applause and the Glitter the Academy
Awards reflect Hollywood in the moment
either leading the way or lagging behind
modern society's expectations back in
1929 there were no black acting nominees
and now 2020 we got one yeah Hollywood
has been confronting societal change for
decades eighty years ago Hattie McDaniel
was the first african-american to win an
Oscar the ceremony held at a segregated
Hollywood hotel and yes last night only
one person of color was nominated in the
main acting categories and she didn't
win nowadays the Academy
seems to be in the political cultural
crosshairs every year there was
criticism that no women were nominated
for Best Director again but Hollywood
has become more conscious of how it
projects itself to the world and the
world still wants to bask in Hollywood's
recognition a salute from South Korea's
president and applause from everyday
South Koreans today still leave it to
the Oscars to shut off the lights during
parasites onstage celebration
it took appeals from a star-studded
audience to shame the producers to put
the no-name Koreans back on camera even
on a groundbreaking night Hollywood can
still trip over its own progress Erik
Sorenson global news toronto and that is
global national for this monday i'm dona
Friesen tonight sir Canada is st.
Nicholas on Prince Edward Island email
your pictures to viewers at global
national calm and thanks for watching
hope to see you here again tomorrow bye
bye